er spricht von der grössten energiekrise
des landes wirtschaftsminister robert
habeck am abend beim bürgerdialog in
bayreuth samt lautstarkem protest
gehören als gesellschaft als
freiheitlich demokratische demokratie
gestärkt aus dieser zeit voraus wenige
stunden zuvor gibt es ein presse
statement gas wird teurer für den
endverbraucher werden
und deswegen werden wir per verordnung
juniper aber auch den anderen
unternehmen die russische gasmengen neu
beschaffen müssen zu höheren preisen
erlauben gehören beschaffungskosten
umzulegen auf die endverbraucher konkret
bedeutet das ab dem ersten oktober muss
jeder der mit gas heizt eine umlage
zahlen damit wird die kilowattstunde 1,5
bis 15 teurer die genaue summe soll bis
ende august feststehen je nach verbrauch
während das pro haushalt mehrere hundert
euro mehrkosten pro jahr gelten soll
diese umlage bis ende märz
2024 für viele verbraucher eine
finanzielle herausforderung wir kriegen
jetzt ja wahrscheinlich den corona
zuschuss ich arbeite in der pflege das
werde ich komplett zur seite legen
weihnachtsgeld und das reicht
hoffentlich um nächstes jahr ja
irgendwie bisschen darüber
hinwegzukommen ich würde natürlich mich
freuen wenn die regierung mal andere
konzepte auf den tisch legt als einfach
nur zu sagen ein bisschen kälter duschen
zum beispiel atomkraftwerke weiter
laufen lässt weil mir auch biogas zu
setzen ich glaube da kann gar nicht
jeder mit sehen was wollen sie machen
mit der familien mit kleinen kindern die
kinder müssen warten die kinder müssen
es warm haben wo wollen sie denn der
anfang zu sparen sorgen rund um die
immer weiter steigenden energiepreise
und die gasknappheit seien laut
energieexperten durchaus berechtigt die
hohen energiepreise die wir jetzt an den
großhandelsmärkten sehen sind noch gar
nicht bei den haushalten angekommen das
heißt wir werden deutliche
preissteigerungen sehen und damit
einhergehend wahrscheinlich eine
bewusstseinsveränderung bezogen auf die
wertigkeit von energie energie war
vorher irgendwie da und auf eine art und
weise immer bezahlbar und jetzt werke
niro energie wird knapp die hohen
energiekosten machen nach wie vor den
löwenanteil der inflation in deutschland
aus energie verteuerte sich im juli um
fast 36 prozent im vergleich zum vorjahr
die inflation liegt aktuell bei 7,5
prozent und hat sich damit leicht
abgeschwächt vor einer möglichen armut
sollen verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
laut habe gezielt geschützt werden nur
wie genau das ablaufen soll darauf hat
der wirtschaftsminister noch keine
konkrete antwort die finanzpolitischen
sorgen und nöte lösen wir so dass wir
den menschen direkt unterstützen geben
die energiepolitischen sorgen lösen wir
so dass wir energie effizienz und die
einsparung aber auch den ausbau von
neuen kapazitäten sowohl fossilen wie
erneuerbaren energien mit druck
voranbringen bislang ist also nur eines
sicher egal wieviel im nächsten winter
gehalt wird es wird ziemlich teuer
und bei mir ist jetzt lorenz gösta
beutin er ist der stellvertretende
parteivorsitzende bei den linken und der
energiepolitische sprecher der linken zu
dem schönen guten morgen
ist es denn eigentlich richtig jetzt die
gasimporteure zu unterstützen
naja es gibt offensichtlich bei
systemrelevanten
gasunternehmen wie juniper die sich
verzockt haben indem sie massiv in kohle
und auch in russisches gas investiert
haben eine notlage und die wir die
bundesregierung auffangen nur die frage
ist wenn man sagt das ist systemrelevant
wer soll für die kosten aufkommen und
wir erleben hier wieder eine situation
wo ein unternehmen sich wirklich
verspekuliert hat und wo das dann auf
die gas kunden umgelegt werden soll und
das ist aus meiner sicht das große
problem aber verzockt ist das dann
richtig ich mein viele regierungen auch
die deutsche hat natürlich auch das gas
aus russland auch vertraut auch
stadtwerke und et cetera die werden ja
auch gestützt naja juniper
beispielsweise ist entstanden aus einer
abspaltung des konzerns eon vor relativ
kurzer zeit und da wusste man schon dass
eben kohle und gas ein auslaufmodell
sind und man wusste schon dass man in
andere geschäftsformen rein gehen sollte
aber selbst wenn man sagt es ist richtig
den konzern jetzt zu stützen weil er ihm
systemrelevant ist für die gasimporte
nach deutschland da muss man doch fragen
wer trägt die kosten
und wir haben gestern zahlen gehört dass
rwe und shell milliardengewinne gemacht
haben shell hat den gewinn verfünffacht
und dann würde ich doch sagen sollte man
nicht er dann
dass man diese über gewinne der konzerne
besteuert und die gaskunden er entlastet
anstatt jetzt noch weiter zu belasten
würde dann staatlichen eingriffen
natürlich bedeutet man kann ja auch
sagen man kann dass die steuern sind
immer ein staatlicher eingriff man kann
das eine tun ohne das andere zu lassen
also man kann
unternehmen stadtwerke etc unterstützung
gleichzeitig bürger und bürgerinnen
entlasten das kostet natürlich dann
werden wir schnell bei der
schuldenbremse etc was fordern sie dann
für weitere entlastungen 30 milliarden
sind ja schon versprochen und in teilen
muss man sagen bisher umgesetzt worden
also wir sagen ganz klar dass wir zum
einen ein gaspreis deckel brauchen dh
dass es einen grund kontingent gibt was
relativ günstig ist und was von den
gaskunden bezogen werden kann denn wir
haben jetzt so exorbitant hohe gaspreise
dass sich viele menschen das nicht mehr
leisten können wir erleben explodierende
mieten wir explorer erleben
explodierende nahrungsmittelpreise und
jetzt oben drauf dann noch so etwas wie
eine gasanlage das bringt menschen in
ihrer existenz die drohen ihre wohnung
zu verlieren und das heißt wir sagen wir
brauchen zum eine energie pauschale für
einkommensschwache haushalte und wir
brauchen auf der anderen seite
selbstverständlich auch höhere sätze für
hartz 4 höhere sätze beim bafög die
wirklich die existenz sichern denn durch
die inflation sehen wir diese beträge
reichen überhaupt nicht mehr aus da der
minister hey was die hartz-iv-sätze
anbelangt sich schon geäußert also da
ist ja auch ein bisschen bewegung drin
welche alternative zum russischen gas
sehen sie denn sie wissen die diskussion
um die drei noch laufenden atommeiler
läuft würden sie da auch diesen
sogenannten streck betrieb erst einmal
umsetzen wollen na wir erleben da gerade
so etwas wie eine geisterdebatte ich
glaube das ist eine große errungenschaft
der anti-akw-bewegung dass wir den
atomausstieg haben und ich erlebe gerade
dass viele die gunst der stunde wittern
raus aus dem atom ausstieg zu gehen und
letztlich nicht nur ein streck betrieb
zu machen sondern wirklich eine
laufzeitverlängerung das kann man ja
festlegen also wenn man sagen ja
wir wissen ja wie so etwas abläuft und
wir wissen dass die fdp in der regierung
massiv druck macht dass die
unionsparteien massiv druck machen und
das gerade die atomlobby auch massiv
druck macht und meine befürchtung ist
das bleibt nicht dabei und schauen wir
uns dass real an dieser bemerkung noch
es geht wirklich um ein prozent der
gasversorgung das heißt die bestehenden
atomkraftwerke im streck betrieb könnten
maximal ein prozent des deutschen
gasbedarfs abdecken und das könnte man
viel besser durch sinnvolle
energieeinsparmaßnahmen
erreichen und dass man beispielsweise
solaranlagen ans netz bringt wir haben
1000 solaranlagen größere solarfelder
die noch immer nicht genehmigt sind und
da sollte man doch ein schnellverfahren
machen und sagt wir bringen die jetzt
ins deutsche deutsche stromnetz rein
wenn das dann schnell geht und ging es
ist das sicherlich noch eine weitere
variante sie haben aber wir erleben beim
lg dass es da sehr schnell gehen kann
warum sollte nicht meine erneuerbaren
auch mal schnell gehen bis herbst und
winter wird es wahrscheinlich nicht aber
man kann sich ja auch für die sing und
rüsten die sind fertig es fehlt nur die
betriebsgenehmigung die müssen nur ans
netz gebracht werden sagt lorenz gösta
beutin stellvertretende
parteivorsitzende von den linken mit
noch mal einer forderung von weiteren
entlastungen wenn man schon unternehmen
retten möchte vielen dank für ihren
besuch vielen dank